I thought that title sequence really
held really did what would we have
without that right no you'll see what
I'm talking about like I was watching
the show little big shots okay
he's watching that very pop yeah little
big shots and I was just watching it for
a bit and then I hit the button and it
said talented young ones are tested when
they confront Steve Harvey's giant T
handling it that's God that's got good
guy got some chompers there I was
watching RuPaul's Drag Race and then I
hit the info button it said what all of
Hollywood looks like to Ted Cruz
supporter yeah I was watching his show
billions
I was watching billions and I hit the
button and it said hey it's that dude
from homeland okay I was watching the
CBS Evening News with Scott Pelley and
then I hit the button and it said the
world events brought to you by a larger
than normal leprechaun
I was watching MasterChef junior with
Gordon Ramsay yeah and then I hit the
button and it said a group of kids are
turned off of cooking forever
watching NCIS
you know those NCIS shows watching NCIS
and then he hit the button have some
detectives in a race against time to
entertain your parents before they we're
on TV
kinda NCIS New Orleans yep then I hit
the button said handsome detectives in a
race against time to entertain y'all's
parents look at this I was watching this
inside the PGA Tour yeah when I hit the
button it said please contact the
hospital staff or about your broken TV
remote
[Applause]
that's watching to show the doctors yeah
yeah watching the show the doctors and
then I hit the button and it said some
of the Caribbeans finest physicians
answer your questions while wearing
rented lab coats and finally and finally
Shahs of Sunset yeah and then I hit the
button it said think the worst Iranian -
the ones who stormed our Embassy in 1979
and held 60 American hostages for every
year pink again
[Applause]
yeah we're gonna take a break from this
Trump rally we'll be back
you